hey youtubers it's Charlie and yesterday
during my Walking Dead episode 13 video
I asked you to submit all your questions
about the WTF moments so I paid ten of
them with one bonus question to answer
in this video generally the biggest
questions were about bets getting
kidnapped
Darrel's and new friends and the
terminus before we get started though
quick high-five to me love to run you
are the week 5 winner of my Walking Dead
giveaway I'll be reaching out to you on
your channel for details if you're
finding me for the first time just as a
way to say thank you to you guys for
being so awesome each week I gave away a
$20 gift card to a random subscriber in
the comments the next round will start
whenever episode 14 airs and I post that
review video so let's answer some
questions there were some good ones this
week number one comes from Andrew Jones
do you think that Glenn is following
Maggie's trail or traveling from a
different direction altogether to
terminus yeah it's totally possible that
those terminus Maps are all over the
place it's hard to guess where Glenn was
the last time we saw him but in my head
I think that everyone either went east
or west using the railroad tracks
Abraham of course was headed a little
bit northeast though it's hard to guess
which way Maggie went when they left the
prison but I think the show wants us to
think that he's coming from behind her
so that's what I'm choosing to believe
yes he is following her circumstances do
seem like they're trying to push all of
the groups towards terminus by the end
of the season though question number 2
Alan Michael asks who do you think is in
terminus so just because the word
sanctuary gets used every time they talk
about terminus or it's shown on screen
I'm choosing to believe that it is the
sanctuary from the comic books which
totally means that if they're doing a
direct adaptation it would be negan and
the Savior's but none of the writers or
cast's have mentioned that so it's
possible that they're just messing with
the story a little bit there's also the
introduction of Daryl's new buddies and
the Gareth character that was announced
last year we still haven't met him so
assuming the show sticks its comic book
guns it'll be the Savior's in sanctuary
even if they don't necessarily use that
name to describe them either way it's
bad very bad question number 3 Carolina
amy asks what do you think those Daryl
and Beth moments throughout the whole
episode met do you think that he will be
the one that rescues or finds her so
that awkward pause between Daryl and
Beth is just her trying to get him to
admit that he's starting to see the more
positive side of things what he didn't
say or said with a shrug was that it was
because Beth had started to rub off
on him that acqua Pazza itself did kind
of make it seem like there was some sort
of implied sexual attraction but I don't
think that Darrell sees it that way I
think that he just cares about her a lot
more than he's willing to say out loud I
do think that since all the groups are
headed towards sanctuary that there's a
strong possibility that he will run into
her there question number four the mouse
Network asks is Gareth the person that
took Beth in the car or was it someone
else so one of the biggest theories
about best kidnapper is that it's the
new character the one that was mentioned
last year Gareth and he's kind of an
amalgam of the father Gabriel character
from the comic books in that story he
was accused of being involved with the
kidnapping of Dale which turned out to
be the hunters there is a rumor that
Gareth is tied to the terminus but
there's no evidence to back it up right
now other than the cross in the back of
that car but I will say that he was
either the one who abducted her in the
car or he orchestrated it either way
he's tied to the sanctuary somehow
question number five Matthew I asked do
you think that any one will make it to
terminus before the season finale or do
you think that everyone makes it to the
terminus in the season finale I
definitely think that most of the cast
will make it to the terminus there's
been so much for shadowing in the last
couple of episodes it would be a huge
audience burn on us if we never actually
got to see it they didn't make it really
explicit in the episode they didn't
explain it but I do think the Joe's
group the one that gel ran into is also
tied to the terminus but I don't think
there's the big bad question number six
mr. pixel 64's do you think those guys
will help Daryl find the car and Beth
they seem pretty terrible so I'm gonna
say no based on everyone slowly being
herded towards terminus though I think
that he'll find her coincidentally I'm
actually really interested to see how
each group is introduced to the
community that already lives there if
it's going to be like their introduction
to Woodbury I have a feeling that
because Joe's group views daryl is
something of a kindred spirit they'll
vouch for him but they still give off a
really murdery vibe so I don't think
he's any safer than any other group
question number seven Liv Taylor asks
how in the world did Daryl let those
guys just sneak up on him like that I
think he had just hit like a new bottom
like spending all that time with Beth
had made him really happy and hopeful
again and then losing her and being on
his own and lost made him die just a
little inside or
died a little bit more he really just
gave up for a little while and given
that they ran into him I think
geographically all the groups are a lot
closer than we think remember Joe is
just at that house where Rick be shown a
Carl were question number 8 filmic Phil
asks do you think that the Gareth
character is going to be a cliffhanger
so I assume you're talking about the
next episode or the finale I think that
we'll meet him before the finale there
were really only three more episodes
left so I don't think this show will go
on any crazy tangents with the exception
of whatever the cliffhanger is for next
season the teaser for the next episode
makes it seem like it will mostly
revolve around Carolyn tyreese's group
we haven't seen Rick Roop in a couple of
episodes and given that we've seen Beth
and Daryl for the last two weeks I don't
think that we're gonna be Gareth until
episode 15 the show has been doing this
weird thing where it focuses on the same
characters for a couple of episodes then
jumps to other groups for a couple of
episodes so I think that the trend will
continue the next episode
it'll just jump to another group that we
haven't seen yet you know Carol Tyreese
obviously question number nine demikhov
that asks do you think the daryl laying
down in the casket was a sign
I certainly hope not daryl is not in the
comics so you can't really say he's
living on borrowed time but he's
definitely really high on the list of
potential deaths there are a couple of
characters that are dead in the comic
books but still alive in the show I
would put them higher than Daryl though
on that potential list of deaths I think
it is highly likely that someone could
die trying to save Beth before the
season finale or in the season finale
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's going to be Daryl I haven't seen
any quotes from Norman Reedus but I do
wonder if he jumped in that coffin on
the spot or if the writers wrote it into
the script question number 10 Aimee
Haines asks if Bob had really been bid
do you not think that he would have
shown at least some signs or even shown
panic whenever saw sure Maggie weren't
around so he did say that the Walker
only graced his bandage so either he's
telling the truth
and Walker teeth you know didn't touch
his flesh or he's lying and just
ignoring the warning sign that Sasha was
talking about one of the things I really
liked about the episode was how
ambiguous it was with the characters
lives it was like everyone almost died
at some point much more so than usual
the writers are doing a really good job
of teasing a big death which I still
think is coming
probably in the season finale and one
last bonus question
Marian Swanson asks do you think that
the show made a mistake by displaying
Abraham's group so faithfully to the
comic books so this is actually a
carryover question from a couple of
episodes ago I saw a lot of you guys
commenting on the appearance the
physical appearance of Abraham and
Rosita specifically mostly that Abraham
was a little too out of shape and Rosita
was just a little too much of a Barbie
doll hot pants for the win
I didn't really mind Abraham's
appearance but I did think that Rosita
seemed a little out of place in the
booty shorts I guess if it's the
apocalypse you just have to do whatever
you can do to feel comfortable I think
it would have been a bigger issue if she
had had more screen time generally I
don't begrudge little things like that
unless the show forces me to stare at
something all the time so thank you so
much to you guys for so many questions
this is a lot of fun as always two big
things that we can look forward to in
the next couple of episodes is one
meeting that Gareth character and two
finally seeing terminus next week Lizzie
and mica look like they're totally in
deep [ __ ] be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'll post it right after the
episode airs
I'm also hurrying to get that Game of
Thrones break that out later tonight too
right now click here to get that
breakdown video and click here to get my
top 5 WTF moments from this Walking Dead
episode thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in a little bit advice